hello and welcome to this video a little
bit later and Hani is the opponent let's
see Ida some message popping up right
when the game was starting so I've got
the the Banco on the board here he
declines it with b6 it's a very
respectable line for white ok so he
allows me to trade the bishop I'm happy
about this development the light squared
Bishop is usually quite useless in the
banco and like is happy to trade it so
what's going on here I want to drink the
night over to be five currently i have b
to attack so there was hoops there was
no Bishop g5 ok so he stopped this the
night be five idea put some more
pressure they're going to be three might
be might be an option ok not anymore did
this he has prevented ok
so cannot develop the bishop and I don't
really know what doubling here is doing
that much but I think I'll do it anyway
double on the be found
h4 h5 is a cool idea yeah I don't know
maybe he wants to bring the rook or
where all the way possible okay so i can
go here you cannot move the beep on now
cannot miss the night cannot move the
bishop so he's somewhat tired my idea is
light if I have to see for now one
Knight b6 to see 400 those to not be six
there might be rupee 3 so this is not so
not so great
the other unprincipled idea is to go see
four and 95 it's also quite good
yeah it's not really not so easy for him
now hit you decide on a plan so 95 one
we are going to see for ya medium I mean
let's let's play it let's see for
attacks the rope so something like night
see 498 2i + 92 immediately ok so I go
back yeah maybe to be six keep the
pressure on b2 intact Queen a5 coupe de
ville de was possible ok so here maybe
c4 or not sure
by the way how how Queen takes between
us that a move ok it's a bit crazy but i
think i get i get another minor piece
and my position is very is very active
so it could work actually if i get get
to double on the second rank this would
work I mean you can recover the Queen
now and return return material but I
hook see one maybe that's it's not so
bad but I don't think you will Quincy
one and the question is what I take I
can take go with them probably this
probably probably this
rooty too though okay i can take a for
them kind of kind of funky I get very
nice activity here the only not good
enough is that not so good as my c7
night that's tricky now I mean so he
gives me f2 I don't want to allow him to
take care
Green age six and that isn't that isn't
threatening all that much Nigerian as
possible check I didn't take on f2 with
the rope because I work to be one okay
yeah maybe night takes you can still not
cover F to the bishop should always who
should you for and knowing that is very
dangerous of course I have to be sure
here group g3 though what am I playing
against that night f2 probably yeah I
can take it I don't know if I should
tell interesting move probably not
red white resigns yeah I don't know if
that objectively worked but it looked
interesting so let's let's let's have a
look or the cool plenty of at the age on
bangle gauge three yeah objectively this
is probably not working yes stock which
gives wider porn but only a pawn so it's
not like it loses immediately yeah the
stock fish mean move is 98 I have
considered that because the night on c7
is not looking great but ok if you a
spot that this move might work I mean
it's kind of meek not to play it ok so
he can try to return to return the
material immediately I wasn't sure about
this position but ok the computer shows
that the I probably will get here with
the bishop and this looks very nice now
and I've got a pawn something that could
could again but ok nobody gives gives us
out so thick steaks and now now he tries
this counter attack check yeah the
engine likes wide I hear Luke g3 year
was was winning also manners message by
my opponent ok hmm
now 97 is better yeah i was a little bit
too relaxed yeah i thought that this is
winning anyway to be honest but it
doesn't seem to be the case i'll go here
and five okay okay that's a strong
attack so that was a Miss 93 okay now
now i'm running for real so I what what
is the entrance written mainline it
wants to take the porn hmm yeah one
reason is that this is tactically
covering Jack on here very unclear
business after the Queen Queen sacrifice
but it was too interesting for me and
not not to try ok guys thanks for
watching